نذهب معكم الان الى صواريخ كنجال او
السلاح المثالي كما يحلو للرئيس الروسي
بلادي تسميته ولم تفوته الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه الجيش الاوكراني اعلن عن اسقاط
سته صواريخ روسيه من طراز كنجال تفوق سرعه
الصوت خلال قصف كثيف واستثنائي على
العاصمه موسكو من جاتها نفط اعتراض صاروخ
كينج زعيمه ان احدها دمر انظمه دفاع الجوي
باتريوت التي قدمتها الولايات المتحده
لاوكرانيا
او الخنجر صاروخ باليسيون يطلق في الهواء
تتباهى روسيا بانه يستطيع التغلب على جميع
انظمه الدفاع الجوي وتصر على قدرته على
عبور اكثر من 11 الف كيلو مترا في الساعه
اي انه عصي على التدمير وفق المزاعم
الروسيه علما بان معظم الصواريخ البالسيه
تستطيع بلوغ سرعه فرط الصوت اي خمس مرات
اسرع من الصوت في وقت ما خلال تحليقها
ووصف رئيس اداره الع اصمه العسكريه القصف
على كيف بانه اقصى عدد من الهجمات
الصاروخيه في وقت قصير وشمل نحو 18 صاروخا
من الجو والبر وحتى البحر
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات